[Music]
i used to think that i wasn't
competitive
eugene it already looked good and it was
such a simple concept
got the phone call thought it was mad
time
under the mountain scrambles it's one of
his trademarks to the front oh he's
caught and he's calling like
they pulled these doors open you've got
20 seconds let's go
and that's the only reason i'm competing
why are you competing to come second
you're not you're competing to come
first right you want to win
it comes richard thompson this is this
is wild
how do i even get my head around this
and like there's this massive warehouse
that we never knew was there
[Music]
we used to do a lot of tag
someone had a like a gopro and um we
just thought
let's um test the gopro and film one of
our games of tags
and um so we put the helmet on and then
we just started playing tag
in the garden and it just kind of shows
how
how the sport has sort of evolved right
[Music]
can you explain to me the basic rules of
a
chase tag match basically there's two
teams
of up to five or six athletes depending
on the tournament
[Music]
[Applause]
each chase lasts 20 seconds
[Music]
one person is a chaser and one person is
an invader and the chase has to try and
tag the vader and the evader has to try
and not get caught
and whoever wins stays on as the evader
that's the most important thing
um so the winner always stays on his
evader and um if the veda can last
20 seconds without getting caught then
they get a point and each match is
basically the best of 16 chases
one of the things that i noticed as a
viewer
is the sort of array of names that
different obstacles have
[Music]
we do we do a clockwise we do a
clockwise overview of
all the obstacles so you've got the
front line people can just jump straight
from a chase plate over the front line
which is like a six foot jump
about three foot up um it's quite
impressive
come across the sisters which are two
boards
you can take off of the first one and
jump the second one or you can do a
double kong
or a dive kong which is when you like
slap with your hands and your bum comes
up in the air
[Music]
after the sisters you get to the back
line and this first obstacle in the back
left is where a lot of
the evaders will start it's called the
tilted cube
again the tilted cube providing a lot of
protection is
also one of the highest places for
people to get tagged
come around the back line which puts you
underneath the mountain
which is this big structure at the back
with two big boards and a big flat board
at the front
all the way at the back we've got the
loading bay this is the back right
you're gonna hit the ridge which is a
really high wall it's probably the
the most likely obstacle to clip your
knees on
[Music]
do you have a breakdown of what makes a
really good or bad chase i think the
definition of a good chase is
the number of of interesting
interactions probably
chasers have a certain kind of dynamic
we kind of look at them as like
interactions and then it chases so
the first four seconds of a chase is
just the
chaser getting towards evader then
there's an interaction
and then and then there's interaction
either he gets caught or he moves on
to another part of the court and then
there's another interaction so there is
a kind of dynamic to a chase
there's a kind of interactions then a
pursuit interaction pursuit interaction
pursuit you know
we have a term called eq which is like
evasion quality and that's like probably
the most important
thing to remember to do with the courts
so if it's a low eq area there's not
much protection
if it's a high e key area there's a lot
of protection
and then we realize the more obstacles
we sort of put in the court
we realize it got more interesting the
more obstacles there were then we
realized actually parkour people
are probably going to be the best
athletes to play because there's so many
obstacles
[Music]
what is going on in this clip i'm coming
up super high
so i can reach above the bar not just
grab it with my fingertips i'm actually
grabbing it with bent arms
then i can load all the weight onto my
lats
transfer underneath the bar with a swing
up to the other side of the bath of a
180
grab the bar again so i've also had to
let go of it to do 180 and then once
i've grabbed i'm re-engaging
all of my like active shoulder movement
so lats a lot of shoulders like pulling
in
and then being able to spot where i'm
going and throw my hips
up above the space that i'm gonna land
on and then land on the balls of my feet
which is like
a must with parkour because if you land
anywhere on the box you could slip if
you land on the edge you've actually got
something to push against and it needs
to be the balls of your feet because if
you land on your toes
you'll slip and if you land in the
middle it will hurt and if you land on
the heels you could slip so it has to be
this is part of your
foot that's strong you're reminding me
of
in those guy richie sherlock holmes
movies when
holmes gets in some sort of situation
count with crossed left cheek
the whole point of parkour like the
philosophy
behind it is basically like self-control
and understanding of your body and
understanding of your surroundings and
stuff like that
how is the parkour world organized into
these teams what are
teams so all these brands came about as
yeah just groups of young lads
who were training together often having
fun and
wanting to try and make a living off of
it that first time that you
tried world chase tech do you remember
how that felt or what you thought
yeah i was really tired he's coming
underneath the sisters
was that attack no britain's still in
pursuit he's managed to go underneath
for ridge bridge
it was like this is really tiring um
but as a parkour athlete you're used to
doing like lines that are like really
really short and explosive
right and you have a preset route like
you don't just run around as people
think like on grooves and like do
anything you don't do that everything's
pretty thought out everything's tested
everything's like
i know what i can do with this it's like
ah it's totally like
instinctual at first because obviously
when you first play
you don't think about tactics you're
just like okay just run
like you know and obviously like you
play the first game you're like oh okay
there's the first two three games you're
like okay there's some strategy to this
you're familiar with in like um any ball
sport you get juking
so you'd go like you're going up to a
player and you divert so it looks like
you're going to go
go one way and you go the other way
that's like a really obvious like
we use duking idling is a great time
but it's when you you've got an obstacle
between you and another person
so there's an impasse and you look like
you're moving
but you're not so you're just you're on
the balls of your feet you're almost
it's like an engine is running and then
it it explodes and that's
it's the build up it's a crescendo
before the like great drop in the music
wait to see look at that yeah giving
them a little bit of hands oh but
there's
proper mental torture almost of like
antagonizing somebody and getting them
frustrated so you know what they're
gonna do you know like
telegraphing something is something
that's really really important
i think that fighting is really really
similar mountain
this could be a first point eugen oh
what can you tell me about this idea of
hurting
one of the techniques would be called
shepherding and i think i'm safe to say
that that's quite well known
yeah i've i've been using herding you
just classed it up like twenty percent
yes chef yeah i mean the name says it is
sort of like
you're doing this you're doing this and
you're keeping them in a corner
and it's like having control over where
they are because
you're almost like you're at their mercy
if you're following them around
religiously whereas if you
are shepherding them and keeping them
into a corner you have control in that
situation
upstairs haroon hanafi maroon hurts
perfectly now nobody has ever managed to
successfully evade haroon in the history
of world chase tag
reversad is really really tricky to do
um and it's basically to keep your eyes
on the opponent as an evader
and run them through
high eq obstacles while they're chasing
you
and i know it's something he's worked on
because i've talked to him i'm
friends with him and he's uh he
basically points
steps up goes up to the mountain drops
down
haroon pointing one way going the other
a trademark of his being a chaser used
to be easier
it's now made a little bit harder
because they they talk about eq evasion
quality
uh quite a lot and they're trying to
increase that what they want to do is
they want to keep the eq at 25
so i used to love chasing because i
thought it was really really easy
and i could get it done but for like
pure glory evasions are like how you get
points right like evasion is how you get
a point and how you get it done
so i love that the most
we always used to play in open garden
and then i remember the day the first
time the obstacles kind of came into it
um christian had cut the hedge and we
started to play around the hedge
clippings
and that was the first time we thought
actually that's pretty that's pretty
good
so it was running based so if you are
fast
and agile then you would dominate then
when we introduced the bench
it was quite a low bench you had to go
over the bench
so it was a different skill yeah we
started in the garden
then we started a meet-up group once it
got to winter people were sliding it was
muddy and it was raining
so we moved into a gym that called our
parkour generations that was um
the the first parkour gym that opened up
in like
in london they had much better obstacles
so we started to like do that but they
were just boxes and bars
we bought some scaffolding and we
basically made our own quad
and this was the definite watershed
moment for us because
we knew it was fun this video of you
guys this is
maybe my favorite footage that i've ever
received from a
source of you guys debating the
placement
of the bars in your in your back garden
barrack and the good thing about it is
that again the eq
the staff is gonna be no thing around
here you'll help the chaser to stop
benny hill
if the bar is here within sort of
actually foot high see the bar there
yeah that's the thing
you actually don't want that bar there
because it might help them come up here
but what the chase would do is that if
someone
flies through from into this hole
and you're there suppose suppose we've
had that conversation a million times
so we just then had to refine the rules
and then we just been refining the quad
and then just refining it and finding it
as we go along
i don't think it's a big priority it's
gonna be a hassle to do it uh let's um
let's you know i think i i i didn't i'll
have to measure up and do it but
yeah i could put one there what is your
name and what is your
primary occupation in the world of
sports commentary
um dan dawson i've ridiculously
accidentally
ended up with this sort of moniker of
dan darts dawson international darts
open the final european tour event of
the year has just played out and it's
been won by
this man the rock star joe cullen and it
is a heartbreaker for franz rich
andy hamilton with a nine daughter and
so you're sort of put in this
interesting position because you have
all this knowledge
about darts in the darts world but then
suddenly you have to become obsessed
with world chase tag in a very short
period of time
somebody i'd worked with on the darts um
had got in touch just
bummed me a speculative email saying i'm
i'm doing a
doing this thing it's like uh it's it's
like a
sport but it's like like tag you know
like the playground game
and then as soon as i i googled it and
had a look
like i was i was blown away i was aware
of parkour but only like when i was a
teenager i think when
it all sort of started happening there
were these impossibly cool french guys
going
uh parkour it's it's a philosophy it is
not a sport it is a way of life and i
remember people just running around as a
teenager like jumping on walls and stuff
a bit like this
the american office geezer who just runs
around shouting parkour
and then to see this turned into an
actual competitive sport
was was cool but i i was i still wasn't
prepared for when i actually got down
there on the day
he cannot get hold of him
i mean look at me i walked into that
place and they all looked like greek
gods i was like i was like jabba the
hutt
being surrounded by like three dozen
luke skywalkers somersaulting all over
the place like
that is not my natural habitat but to go
in there and just try and learn that
speaking to damien and christian about
how they came up with the game and the
concept
connor was invaluable when i was working
with him just to try yeah i got him to
just walk me around the quad
over the sisters around towards his
front line looking to cut down the angle
and does so
crazy play he had to make up for lost
time from a small slipper
early on he's managed to run chasing
down across the front line
and get down on top of the other player
i'm learning as much as anybody else
about this it's a new sport for
everybody to get their head around
[Music]
what makes you the people who are in the
rain
assembling the scaffolding debating the
placement of a bar
what what drives this obsession for you
i wanted to see the best people chase
and i i
really hope there's a day where people
are you know
at the age of eight they get into chase
tag and they just
train the whole time and i'd love to see
them when they're 25 or 28 at the peak
of their physical condition
training against other people who have
also trained since they were eight i
will go to sleep at night
some nights like when i'm really like
preparing for a competition like
thinking about roots and lines and
things i go
like down a rabbit hole you think in
your head
your your little vision of yourself you
go yeah i can do i can do
all of that absolutely all of it and
then you realize that you can't even
carry your washing upstairs without
tripping over
the cat or something when we do parkour
we say we're training
like we're training like what are we
training for and i suppose you could say
it was a situation in which you're
chasing or evading someone
so it's almost like world chase tag is
like the thing that we are preparing
ourselves for
i start describing how the sport works
and as
i'm describing it i get like a feedback
loop of
man this sounds really good i'd love to
watch this
you just see how similar like we all
are regardless of actually where we're
from you know and this is this is a
really interesting
element for me that all humans could be
united by this one activity
that they all do
[Music]
that's a giant skull in the background
[Music]
do you want scholar no skull skulls fine
[Music]
at the time when lockdown first happened
we were sort of tentatively talking
about having quite a few events
i think we had a european championship
sort of penciled in
we had a potential event in saudi arabia
pennsylvan
we also had an america what was going to
be the world championships in america
and then as soon as lockdown came up we
just realized that you know none of that
was gonna happen
our final decision which is sort of
encouraged by the investors that we have
at the moment
they said okay let's do a u.s national
event and that's what we ended up doing
in october
in atlanta
another thing that like that came
positive
out of the lockdown what happened in the
uk
was we got really good weather and
normally
when we have the quad up we only put the
quad up
for events so we have we book a space we
put the quad up
and that's the only time me and damon
get to see it
up and we could never use it because all
the athletes want to train on it
so during lockdown when we had the good
weather we decided to put the quad up
it's first time we died and so for us we
had
more time on the quad than we've ever
had before
you